foreign
[Music]
you will learn how to get started with
troubleshooting a high availability sap
system using Cloud logging
some of the most frequently asked
questions by sap system administrators
are why did my compute instance restart
why did pacemaker restart my instance
why did my sap system fail over or
alternatively Why didn't it fail over to
analyze pacemaker logs in Cloud logging
you should have a basic understanding of
how pacemaker works and its terminology
check out this blog post for a refresher
this video also assumes you have
configured your pacemaker cluster by
following Google's best practices which
you can review in these links for Susie
and red hat and finally your Sap's
instances must already have Google cloud
Ops agents installed and configured to
stream pacemaker logs into Cloud logging
check out this video on how to do this
or you can follow this blog post which
provides a step-by-step guide to set up
the Ops agent on your sap system towards
the end of this blog post you will find
a template of a cloud logging query that
we will be demonstrating in this video
let's take a closer look at this query
it allows you to view the most critical
pacemaker actions and events to use it
simply replace the instance name 1 and 2
with the actual instance names of the
two cluster nodes
this query captures pacemaker actions on
cluster nodes and resources such as
start stop or promote and since we're
troubleshooting we're looking for
operations that have failed along with
the other critical log events this
filter includes log entries on custom
membership changes for example when an
instance becomes unresponsive and
chorusync communication errors and
finally the last two filters will
include fencing actions and the reasons
such as loss of cluster nodes or
resource failures and the results of
these actions
let's apply this query to a real example
and explore the results in this scenario
you have observed that a compute
instance named Hana primary unexpectedly
restarted and you would like to
understand why here the instance names
have been defined as Hana primary and
Hana secondary and the time has been
narrowed down to the time frame of the
restart
the first step is to scroll through the
query results in chronological order
until you can find a block of log
entries labeled log actions they
describe actions affecting the cluster
resources such as moving a resource from
one cluster to another or stopping a
resource on a cluster node most
importantly we can see that an action
was taken to promote the instance Hana
secondary to become the new primary host
in other words a failover took place
to understand the reason for these
actions look at the preceding logs this
log entry tells us the instance Hana
primary was rebooted because it was no
longer part of the cluster in other
words pacemaker detected that a node
left the cluster unexpectedly typically
this happens when the VM itself becomes
unresponsive
unfortunately pacemaker logs won't help
determine why it was unresponsive for
further Clues consider investigating the
operating system logs
to reboot an instance pacemaker will
send an asynchronous request to the
Google Cloud API which you can identify
by looking at this log entry this is the
fencing action
pacemaker reports that the reboot
operation was okay this can also be
confirmed by the second recess request
shown here this is the api's response to
the asynchronous reset request which was
successful
meanwhile while fencing the problematic
instance on a secondary confirmed to
have been promoted to become primary
host for the sap system and thereby
successfully completing the failover
now let's explore when there are no
issues with the compute instance but the
sap Hana database itself has become
unresponsive on the primary host
once again scroll through the query
results until you find the set of log
entries labeled log actions the
preceding log entries suggest that the
sap Hana system was in an unhealthy
State and was not responding normally in
such a scenario the pacemaker is
configured to perform a site takeover or
in other words a failover but based on
this log entry we learned that the
secondary site was not in a synchronized
State at that time simply referred to as
fail because of this pacemaker prefers
to restart the sap database locally on
the original primary instance
pacemaker logs won't help determine the
cause of why the sap database was
unhealthy or unresponsive for this
consider investigating the ACP logs for
further Clues as a Next Step
let's take a closer look at how
pacemaker determines whether a site is
an S fail prior to sap Hana 2 sp3
pacemaker relied on the python script
system replication status.pi to
periodically verify that the primary and
secondary sites are in sync if Hana
fails to respond within the 5 Second
timeout window there can be a false
positive scenario where a synchronized
Honda system is incorrectly marked as s
fail this is common when the system is
under heavy load as a solution to this
scenario Susie and red hat recommends
implementing Sr hook with Sr hook
instead of polling Hanover the
replication status Hana itself will
report any change to its replication
status to pacemaker
this way pacemaker no longer needs to
rely on the system replication status.pi
script to monitor the replication status
with a few Cloud login filters and
understanding what to look for you can
now troubleshoot issues with high
availability SCP systems check out the
description below with more helpful
links to learn more about Sr hook on
Susie's official GitHub page review
Google's srhook implementation
guidelines for Susie and red hat and how
to troubleshoot Sr hook issues
thanks for watching
[Music]